um i have a question that um
actually isn't really my question but
it's a question that's uh
that a lot of people have nonetheless
basically it's
if you've been praying for someone for a
long time say since when you're
very very young
and there seems to be no apparent change
you know saying like if they
say if you have a mother or father is
not a christian or things like that all
right
so how do you not lose heart or what do
you what do you do okay all right let's
pray again father as i continue to
answer questions help me tell me what to
tell you are people whom you love in
jesus name i pray amen
moses's life is divided into three
sections what are the three sections
yes the first 40
the next 40 in the wilderness first in
egypt the next 40 leading the israelites
let's look at the middle 40 it took god
40 years
to get out of moses
what he learned in egypt
now
if god took 40 years
i can pray for 20. are you following me
because i'm praying on an issue that's
precisely god's will
but the long praying may end up changing
me
not just the person i'm praying for it
may end up changing me you see god
cannot be fully understood counts now by
searching find out god god may realize
the person you're praying for i've got
that person covered i want you changed
and by putting you in a situation where
you need to pray you may change
isaac prayed for 20 years before he got
a son if you read genesis 25 verse 20
and isaac was 40 years old when he took
rebecca to wife the daughter of bethel
the syrian of paranaram the brother the
to laban the syrian now that's genesis
25 verse 20.
in verse 26 verse
26 yes
of the same chapter and isaac was three
school years when she beared them
he married her when he was 40. she had
them even 60. he prayed 20 years
genesis 12 verse 5 and abram was set 12
verse 4 neighbor was 75 years old when
he came into canaan 75.
we know he was 100 years old when he had
ice how long did he pray
years
the object of praying
the primary object of praying is not to
get something from god
the primary object of praying is to
fellowship with god
are you with me we must stop seeing god
as an atm machine
god loves to fellowship when you pray
you are hanging out with god
when you study the bible you're hanging
out with god the father god the son god
the holy ghost and the angels now why do
i say that
in daniel chapter eight
and i heard a man's voice between the
banks of oolai which called and said
gabriel make this man to understand the
vision daniel 8 verse 16 god told
gabriel help daniel to understand the
word are you with me when you study the
word angels are sent
but jesus said in john 16 13 how be it
when he the spirit of truth is come he
will guide you into all truth we have
the spirit and the angels assisting you
in acts chapter 8. the angel told philip
take that way
when philip got near to the chariot of
the ethiopian you know the spirit said
go to the chariot we have angel and
spirit associated with someone
understanding the word when you study
god's word you are hanging out with god
and the spirit
and the son who himself is the word and
the angels
when you pray
you are fellowshipping with god it is
not just gimme gimme gimme
yes there's a time for give me give me
give me but praying cannot be seen as a
transactional event it is fellowship
with god
spending time
in god's divine presence so that we
emerge with our faces shining like moses
after 40 uninterrupted days of exposure
to god's glory when you're praying for
someone's salvation you pray until you
die or the person dies
the bible says in second peter chapter
three verse nine the lord is not slack
concerning his promise as some men come
slackness but is
long-suffering to us word
one of the qualities of god is he's long
suffering not willing that any should
perish but it all should come to
repentance if god is long-suffering we
are ideally made in the image of god we
should be what
long suffering
pray for that person pray for that
person and remind god
you said first timothy chapter 2 verse 4
i will have all men to be saved and to
come unto the knowledge of the truth you
remind god if anything is god's will it
is the salvation of your husband who
left you your wife your children who are
out in the world your whomever god wants
to save that person calvary is proof
keep praying but remember
whether you remember or not the act of
praying
ideally will change you
not just the person for whom you're
praying
keep praying
keep praying please the bible says pray
without cease and that's not symbolic
that's literal in me always in contact
with heaven
thanks for the question next one
you